A few weeks ago I met Emily. This wonderful, elegant person.
- You drink? Does your kid drink? I mean, it's never too early for a teaching moment. - I think you're joking, but, great.
Every time we do this I feel so high tone.
She's an enigma, my wife. You can never quite reach her.
Did you just take my picture?
Erase it. - I guess I'm probably not the kind of person you're normally friends with
Oh, you do not want to be friends with me. Trust me.
Five days ago Emily went missing.
I warned you. You go poking around in her past, you're gonna find something that is terrifying.
I smell her perfume like a ghost. - It's just you're being paranoid.
I saw my mom.
She told me to say hi to Stephanie.
People do terrible things for their own reasons.
Honor your secret. A simple favor. In theaters, September 14th
Everybody has a dark side. Some of us are better at hiding it than others. - I don't know your secret, tell me. - No, I don't know, I shouldn't...
You go first.
People do terrible things for their own reasons. A simple favor. In theaters September 14th won't read confessions
Wanna trade confessions?
Come on, what's the wildest thing you've ever done?
Every time we do this I feel so high tone.
Five days ago Emily went missing. You go poking around in her past. You're gonna find something that is terrifying.
People do terrible things for their own reasons.
A simple favor. In theaters, September 14th